is it us or do gwen stefani and blake
shelton
seem permanently cuffed and it's one of
those once in a lifetime
you know moments over the weekend the
pop star who was engaged to the voice
coach
stepped out with her man in santa monica
looking lovey-dovey while rocking
matching
outfits both wearing navy blue baseball
caps and navy tops with light denim
jeans
but the most surprising accessory of
their casual fit was
this diamond sparkler on gwen's finger
next to her
engagement ring that looks like a
wedding band
which begs the question did blake and
gwen secretly get hitched
we think about this e.t reached out to
reps for the couple who couldn't confirm
or deny
their possible union but we do know a
wedding can't be too far away
as gwen's family treated her last
thursday to a surprise bridal shower
i got kidnapped by my family
to celebrate
[Music]
i'm getting married she also revealed
some of her gifts
including a heartfelt card that included
something old
a copy of the masked booklet from her
parents wedding back in 1966.
are you are your eyes watery yes
gosh blake and gwen got engaged in
october 2020 and have been together
since 2015.
both of our lives have basically fallen
completely apart
and uh and little did we know it
happened to both of us
at the same time and uh we bonded over
that
and then you know it's so somewhere in
in that
you know that time of of just
you know darkness was this ended up
being
the greatest moment of my life you know
so it's just it's amazing it truly is
as for the wedding timeline back in
march blake did reveal on the today show
that he and gwen hope to get married
sometime this summer
with kova dislike it looks like it may
be okay but i don't know
so the country star also told hoda copy
there might be a few celeb guest
performances
including former voice coach miley cyrus
and his bestie
adam levine you know it's starting to
sound like
a coachella lineup here all of a sudden
i've got all these superstars standing
on to it we really don't know you know
and i'd love to to be able to take
everybody up on their offer and have
this
amazing concert wedding and of course we
can't count out former voice coach nick
jonas
who told et last month that he wouldn't
be opposed to making an appearance
i'm sure it's going to be a fun night
i'm sure there will be lots of wonderful
beverages
uh involved and i'm so happy for them i
wish them all the best and if you tried
to recruit you as the entertainment or
maybe you and your brothers would you
say yes
very expensive we are very expensive so
blake
you know we gotta dish it out but if
gwen and blake did secretly tie the knot
we'd have to assume they would have kept
their nuptials very low key
which gwen told seth meyers on his show
back in april
that's what she'd prefer i think that's
probably very
simple really simple i i think that the
guest list
will not have a lot of musicians is
going to be like my mom and my dad
like just literally going to be just
family
and um we are looking forward to that
though it's gonna be fun
we're gonna make it really fun but it's
not gonna be a big like
you know it's not like the queen and
king are getting married
you